en los camerinos. (Risas)
También nos referimos a las afecciones subclínicas.
Hay aterosclerosis subclínica, endurecimiento de las arterias subclínico,
obviamente vinculado a ataques cardíacos, potencialmente.
Uno de mis favoritos se llama acné subclínico.
Si investigan sobre acné subclínico, quizá encuentren un sitio, como yo hice,
que dice que este es el tipo de acné más fácil de tratar. (Risas)
No tienen las pústulas o el enrojecimiento y la inflamación.
Tal vez porque en realidad no tiene acné.
Mi apelativo para todas esas afecciones, es otra enfermedad preexistente:
yo las llamo absurdas. (Risas)
En el béisbol, el juego sigue el prejuego.
Las temporadas siguen las pretemporadas.
Pero en la mayoría de estas enfermedades, ese no es el caso, o al menos no siempre.
Es como si siempre hubiese un retraso por la lluvia en muchos casos.
Tenemos lesiones precancerosas
que no siempre se convierten en cáncer.
Y, sin embargo, si tomamos, por ejemplo,
la osteoporosis subclínica, un mal del adelgazamiento de los huesos,
la enfermedad preexistente,
también conocida como osteopenia,
tendríamos que tratar a 270 mujeres durante 3 años
para evitar que se rompan un hueso.
Son muchísimas mujeres,
cuando se multiplica por el número de mujeres diagnosticadas
con esta osteopenia.
¿No es de extrañar,
teniendo en cuenta todos los costos y los efectos secundarios
de los medicamentos para el tratamiento de estos males preexistentes, que cada año
gastemos más de dos billones de dólares en atención médica y sin embargo,
100 000 personas al año –y eso es una estimación conservadora–
mueren no por causa de las enfermedades que tienen,
sino por los tratamientos que les damos y las complicaciones de los mismos?
Hemos medicalizado todo en este país.
A las mujeres en la audiencia,
les tengo muy malas noticias que ya conocen
y es que hemos medicalizado cada fase de su vida.
El primer strike es cuando llegan a la pubertad.
Ahora tienen algo que les sucede una vez al mes y que está medicalizado.
Es un trastorno que debe ser tratado.
Segundo strike viene si se embarazan
y también está medicalizado.
Deben probar la tecnología de punta en el embarazo,
de lo contrario algo puede ir mal.
Tercer strike es la menopausia.
Todos sabemos qué pasó cuando millones de mujeres
recibieron terapia de reemplazo hormonal
para los síntomas menopáusicos durante décadas,
hasta que de repente nos dimos cuenta, por los resultados de un estudio grande,
financiado por los Institutos Nacionales de Salud (NIH) que decía:
en realidad, mucho de la terapia de reemplazo hormonal
puede hacer más daño que bien a muchas de estas mujeres.
Por si acaso, no quiero dejar de lado a los hombres,
soy uno de ellos, después de todo.
Tengo muy malas noticias para todos Uds. en esta sala
y para todos los que nos escuchan y ven en otros lugares:
todos Uds. tienen una enfermedad universal y mortal.
Esperen un momento.
Se llama “premuerte”. (Risas)
Todos y cada uno de Uds. la tiene, porque tienen el factor de riesgo
que es estar vivo.
Pero tengo algunas buenas noticias
porque soy periodista y me gusta terminar las cosas
de una manera feliz o visionaria.
Y esa buena noticia es que si pueden sobrevivir hasta el final de mi charla,
veremos si eso les ocurre a todos,
serán “presupervivientes”.
Ya antes inventé lo de la “premuerte”,
pero si he tomado ese término de otra persona, pido disculpas,
creo que lo he inventado.
Pero no he inventado presuperviviente.
Presuperviviente es lo que algún grupo de apoyo a personas con cáncer
quisiera llamar a los que sólo tienen un factor de riesgo,
pero no han tenido ese cáncer.
Ustedes son presupervivientes.
Estuvo gente de HBO aquí esta mañana.
Me pregunto si Mark Burnett, está aún entre el público;
me gustaría sugerirle un programa de telerrealidad
llamado “Presuperviviente”.
Si Uds. desarrollan una enfermedad, quedan fuera de la isla. (Risas)
Pero el problema es que tenemos un sistema
que es completamente...
básicamente promovió esto.
Hemos seleccionado, en cada punto de este sistema,
hacer lo que hacemos y dar a todos una condición preexistente
y finalmente una enfermedad, en algunos casos.
Comencemos con la relación médico-paciente.
Los médicos, la mayoría, tienen un sistema de pago por servicio.
Prácticamente los incentivan a realizar
más procedimientos, exámenes,
prescripciones de medicamentos.
Los pacientes acuden a ellos, quieren hacer algo.
Somos estadounidenses, no podemos quedarnos de brazos cruzados;
tenemos que hacer algo. Y lo que quieren son medicamentos,
un tratamiento, que se les diga lo que tienen y la forma de tratarlo.
Si el médico no lo hace, irán a otro lugar.
Eso no es muy bueno para el negocio de los médicos.
O peor aún, si les diagnostican algo
y el médico no ordenó las pruebas, los demandan.
Tenemos las compañías farmacéuticas que constantemente tratan de ampliar
las indicaciones y el número de personas elegibles para un tratamiento dado,
porque eso, obviamente, incrementa sus ingresos.
Tenemos grupos de apoyo, como el que ha surgido con el presuperviviente,
que quieren hacer que más y más personas sientan
que están en riesgo o que podrían tener una enfermedad,
para así recaudar más fondos y aumentar su visibilidad, etc.
Pero, no se trata, a pesar de lo que los periodistas suelen hacer,
no se trata de culpar a unos jugadores en particular.
Todos somos responsables.
Yo soy responsable.
De hecho, apoyo a los Yankees,
me refiero a apoyar al peor delincuente posible,
cuando se trata de hacer todo lo que se puede hacer.
Gracias. (Risas)
Pero cada uno es responsable.
Fui a la escuela de medicina
y nunca llevé cursos llamados “cómo pensar con escepticismo”
o “cómo hacer para no ordenar exámenes”.
Tenemos este sistema
en el que eso es justamente lo que hacemos.
Es más, tuve que ser un periodista quien entendiera todos estos incentivos.
Ya saben, a los economistas les gusta decir
que no hay gente mala,
solo hay malos incentivos.
Y efectivamente, eso es cierto.
Porque hemos creado una especie de “Campo de sueños”
cuando se trata de la tecnología médica.
Al traer otra máquina para resonancia magnética, estamos llevando al hospital
un robot que dice que todos debemos hacernos una cirugía robótica.
Bueno, hemos creado un sistema en el que si lo construyes, ellos vendrán.
Pero en realidad se puede convencer
perversamente a gente sana de que tienen que venir.
Al hacerme periodista, me di cuenta realmente que yo era parte del problema